he takes her throughout the house open
safes he even gets her on the computer
and gets her to log into the bank
account and he checks all their Bank uh
accounts how much money they have and at
this point three hours into it the
police aren't knocking on these doors in
this neighborhood yet one of my uncles
is the major and he called and uh he's
not related to them but he knows them
really well and he's like and my aunt
answered he let her answer but he had a
gun to her head
and this is this is funny but [__] up
he's she goes he goes well where's so
and so and my aunt says he's a little
tied up right now on the phone I swear
to god dude I swear to God and uh she
plays it off yeah oh he's got a gun on
her while she's talking
the Honeydew with y'all subscribe today
[Music]